for more on this trend we're joined by
Professor Michael C burda from the
economics faculty abalones Humboldt
University first of all welcome to our
show and the first obvious question
would be what's your part time job I
work in the backyard in our garden
planting and growing and putting
fertilizer around ok doesn't count as a
mini job though but your wife will be
happy about it now then this this trend
here in Germany for people to have more
than one job one main job and then one
or two other jobs is fairly new how do
you explain this trend why can't they
make ends meet anymore Germany well it's
one way of getting people into more
salary without buying into the
inflexibility of a wage increase that
may not be able to be sustainable in the
future the world is changing we're
competing with China and India and
Brazil in the United States as well
these these pressures on firms make them
very conservative in terms of wage
policy but the economy is doing better
so the fraction of people who have some
sort of mini job or nay Punjab extra job
has increased in Germany as a fraction
of total employed mm is it actually a
bad thing this trend of having more than
one job I don't think so it's because it
takes two to tango you need to have
someone to take the job at someone to
offer the job and I think a lot of
people we've seen actually want to work
less and working less one way to do that
is to take a job with lower hours some
people want to work more in a normal
traditional job that wasn't always
possible without overtime and over time
is the thing of the past in Germany now
people take time and vacation or they
take a mini job the mini job also
entails some sort of incentive a tax
incentive we don't go into in all its
depth of German tax system is very very
complicated but it's interesting why
would the German tax office reward
people who do a mini job well it's one
way of getting people out of
unemployment so we've seen the data that
one of the first paths out of
unemployment is into a less well-paying
job it's not the only path but it's one
way to get on your way to a to get the
work experience to get back into the
labor
market and in a sense you think of this
is sort of a tax subsidy it's a way of
making it easier for firms to pay for
these people are all it's also easier
for the employer to fire these people so
this hire and fire scheme is sort of
being introduced through the back door
then isn't it that's right but it's fair
to say that the number of the fraction
of people who are working only at a low
paying job a mini job as they called in
Germany has actually fallen because the
total employment in Germany has risen in
the past few years so it's it's not fair
to say this is a sign of ms eration of
the German worker okay then let's look
across the Atlantic you you're from the
United States and I believe that
low-paid jobs is a big topic over there
as well how does the Germany compare
well there this tax subsidy we just
talked about doesn't exist in the United
States so whether you work 20 hours or
40 hours the the social security
contributions are the same so it's
really a matter of indifference most
workers would like to work more and
those that don't will work less but in a
recession it means a lot of people's
hours will be reduced and now the
recovery is coming back to the United
States this has gone down so a good sign
is the labor market the United States
does work ok professor Buddha thank you
very much for joining us thank you